[Musique]
les élus du conseil départemental se
sont réunis ce mercredi 22 mars dans
l'hémicycle du Palais de la source pour
la première séance plénière de l'année
2023 en ouverture deux séances
l'assemblée a assisté à un petit cours
d'histoire donné par le géographe Mario
serviable à l'occasion des 230 ans de
l'appellation
île de la Réunion à cette occasion les
élus ont pu découvrir trois documents
originaux sortis exceptionnellement des
magasins des Archives départementales
se rappelle historique a ensuite laissé
place à l'examen des dossiers inscrits à
l'ordre du jour notamment le plan
d'action 2023 2024 en faveur de la
réussite des jeunes à hauteur de 11
millions d'euros ou encore la
réglementation départementale en faveur
du sport et des sportifs de haut niveau
l'assemblée a travaillé sur des sujets
éminemment important puisque cela
concerne les jeunes les jeunes en grande
difficulté la jeunesse vulnérable nous
avons mis en place un rapport qui
renforce donc l'accompagnement vers une
bonne assiation une association durable
voilà les jeunes qui rencontrent des
difficultés c'est important nous avons
aussi travaillé sur la valorisation des
jeunes qui à travers le sport veulent
aller le plus loin possible le sport de
haut niveau et donc nous avons modifié
notre régime de bourse pour que les
jeunes puissent être mieux accompagnés
financièrement quand il s'engage dans
des activités sportives de haut niveau
les élus du département ont également
abord le sujet des enfants placés et de
leur prise en charge en votant pour une
revalorisation des différentes
indemnités nous avons aussi travaillé en
faveur des jeunes qui relèvent de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance et je salue le
travail des travailleurs familiaux des
assistants familiaux qui reçoivent qui
aident qui éduquent qui accompagne les
jeunes enfants en grande difficulté
l'enfance vulnérable et donc face à cela
nous avons travaillé dans le cadre d'un
dialogue social pour que les métiers
de travailleurs sociaux d'assistant
familiaux soient revalorisés
revalorisation des métiers d'assistant
familiaux et en même temps aussi donc
une revalorisation de tout ce qui touche
à l'aide à ses enfants l'aide à
l'éducation l'aide à la prise en charge
de la dépense quotidienne tout cela a
été corrigé et augmenté
une fois l'examen des différents
rapports terminés cette séance plénière
c'est ensuite achevée sur une séquence
émotion avec la remise de la médaille
départementale du mérite à René Robert
géographe et chercheur ce professeur
émérite a contribuer à la définition des
politiques sur l'environnement à la
Réunion il est également l'une des
chevilles ouvrières qui ont travaillé
pour l'inscription des python cirque et
remparts au patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO une distinction remise sous les
applaudissements de l'assemblée et
célébrer en musique avec un champ sur le
thème de la protection de la nature
interprétée par Davy Sicard et les
membres du conseil départemental des
jeunes
[Musique]